[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
hello how are you
how's everyone doing
am i good at streaming
oh no that's not the link
so this stream is uh
to join thank ms 2020 hosted by
jacksepticeye
it all goes to red nose day if you want
to donate
link in description yeah
it's already done amazing he already hit
the goal
that's nuts
i'm gonna play with jack uh in an hour
but for now
we'll cyber punk it up yeah
cyberpunk i really like cyberpunk
i'm just uh
i'm so confused on how to do let's plays
i don't know if it's of my age
or uh what happened but it just seems
like i'm pissing everyone off
by [ __ ] around too much i keep
singing it
and i kept thinking like every video
every stream i guess it happened in
other games too like goes to sushima and
honestly it's always happened like
unless i play the game perfectly people
say a bunch of [ __ ]
um
but i was just like i don't get it why
are people so pissed off
about story and cyberpunk it's not even
much of a story to begin with
like out of this out of all game people
really want to know the story and then i
i thought about it for so long i'm like
i don't get it like what am i missing
here
why is this so upsetting to some people
i think i think i
finally figured out i don't know why it
took me so long it's like
yeah i'm playing the game i'm having fun
with the gameplay
but for the ones that are watching
i mean story is like their version of
the gameplay
does that make sense that's their your
only way to enjoy the game so if i'm
just going
to the show i get that that's
distracting
i guess i always thought like hey just
go watch someone else if you're really
like there's so many people playing
these games i i bring my own flavor to
it
but i'll see if i can find some sort of
middle ground
i'll meet you halfway yeah broseph
vlogger
nice what's what's she reading
kibble and scop great
music to my ears
i'm not showing the screen hold up see
[Laughter]
yeah we're back even people saying like
he doesn't seem like he likes the game
so lame i'm like but i said i was
enjoying it damn
i want this setup all right
roll it data was in pretty rough shape
not all that editable
thank you nicholas glad you mentioned
appreciate your man first place
needs a second to load maybe i
i was literally like am i too old to
play games but i did what i could
[Music]
i i think i said this before and it
sounds very pretentious but
what am i looking out for every single
piece of tech i see
security we need a layout of the
yeah i'll finish my rant after this bit
of story
i think i recognize these they
come on you familiar with them not
enough to know what they actually mean
heard of who might use them though
sorry that kind of encryption's easy to
crack
but not this time whoever she is she's
got serious net running skills
that or someone's working it for her
yeah okay what i was saying if he starts
talking about the bio chip
himself
did i not scan them
[Music]
maybe or maybe not from pacifica
now is down our search at least what now
looks like i'm going to field talking
about the biochip
himself
that is not of interest
[Music]
what do you think absolutely incredible
looks like evelyn never told us the
whole truth
you're telling me if i'd known what
she'd gotten herself into
i'm so mad at her me too used to record
a virtue
it's pretty damn amazing she managed to
organize a full-blown heist
and swipe the biochip from under her
boss's noses
so that's where you came in she hired
you
and brought this all on herself
on youtube there's one more recording
wanna see it
no
okay turn up game uh
okay no i can't i literally can't uh
okay i know this sounds pretentious and
it probably is
but reading books have just ruined
stories in video games for me because
it's game stories are always
so mediocre at least
there's not okay they they play their
part it's a story and
and sure great but very rarely are they
good
very rarely i would say and uh
that's why i just i struggle to get
engaged more than i use sooner
i think also playing games for so long
you know kind of what to expect
it seems like story is always an
afterthought in games too
which makes sense there's a lot of
elements you have to sort of complement
each other with but yeah
it's also so many redundant sentences
and dialogues it just feels like they're
speaking for
talking saying they're talking we're
talking saying sure why not nothing can
surprise me at this point
[Music]
there's no deeper meaning philosophy
ideas it's usually just like hey
i [ __ ] killed this guy [ __ ] yeah we
have to get the zorgon in the bar bars
[Music]
okay
that's just my take on it but yeah i i
understand different people's
perspective on it
i hate to be so cynical
i don't know haitian creole it is the
voodoo boys
didn't i wait let me see if i've got an
auto translator
meantime you try to tune into the
phone's frequency
see what the other side's saying
see what the other side
i'm trying
sounds like jacksepticeye speak it's
green as well to know what they're
saying
it could be important fine
just found the auto translate package
should get along fine with your system
i'll install it now
thank you
[Music]
i like the game i like playing it i'm
just saying like
okay judy we're good we're good all
right glad we didn't
see weren't you glad you did that
i don't get it what's this have to do
with johnny silverhand
hey he died like forever ago
lee you got any idea
a biochip we stole it's uh
it's got silver hands engram burned onto
it
engram digitized psyche
on the smoke
[Music]
can you give me a minute i need to go
over some stuff
in my head um of course
i need to talk to keon
these people what could they want from
all i still don't have pants jesus
christ
a youtuber set up one way or another
everything leads back to that netrunner
finding hers our biggest priority if she
knows as much as i think she knows about
the chip
she can help us out i thought you said
no is he he's not even moving his lips
dude all right just
find us juju wirehead okay
hell yeah hell yeah
um
yes wait you got any idea how to get in
touch with the voodoo boys
i'll ask around make a few calls let me
put it this way
the voodoo boys wouldn't trust a cat if
i walked onto their turf
but someone's gotta know way in well
good luck
i hope you won't need it
hey love a lot at least we can get some
different katanas and [ __ ]
no v thank you you're
you're a good person evelyn could never
see what was under people's skin
thank you i know i'm a good person i
don't even listen to this [ __ ]
oh this gun though
oh oh i like this
[ __ ] yeah the rain looks good in this
okay is it side quest time
i want a difficult one
go to the fight in arroyo
this is like a boxing fight or something
i want a bang bang fight
animal club i swear we were there
maybe this
oh that's a random ass one let's do this
definitely meant to do that
there she is hell yeah
someone said this bike is actually from
keanuri's company or something that he
owns and is actually modeled from it
[ __ ] [ __ ]
best driver as always thank you
thank you
hey how you doing got a rap problem on
my block
who doesn't right thing is these rats
are human sized
look just like tiger claws too she's
flying biggest one
is a certain tacky she is oh there you
go do your fixer
solid and neutralize her ass will ya
i like how it's not just buggy for some
people
not playing the pc version too i can't
even imagine how the
xbox and playstation are
there we go this is the animal club no
this is a pachinko oh i want to check
out some pachinko
that might be fun
do you hear what happened in number five
what
he beat her again no she flatlined him
shot him dead you know
waiting for the dreamcast release nice
i won't play pachinko bro i'm talking to
you
yeah what do you want what
what the [ __ ] did i do
i am interested damn this gun is good
hey what the [ __ ]
give me my sword hold up let me just get
my sword
thank you
[Music]
oh yeah
bro you suck
legs
mine what the [ __ ]
i did not present
i just want to play pachinko
nice
it wasn't me i swear
hey pachinko yay move away
how do i play
wait are you time for [ __ ] sake you
can't play them
no give me that
was an x move away from the pachinko
machines
i did it
that's what it's all about one less
tiger in this town
appreciate your problem solving skills
no worries
how you guys doing some crazy guy with a
sword in there
shoes are for cowards you got that god
damn right
wait oh [ __ ] sake i missed clint
nope yeah
three kilometers that's what i want
no
sorry sorry bro
[ __ ] sorry bro what
[ __ ] sorry bro sorry bro
yeah the game is good it's just not
finished
that's the problem they must have known
how [ __ ] the game what
what is happening
they nail the atmosphere though their
styling the music is [ __ ] great
live nude okay
oh what a turn
get out of the road
sorry bro
sorry
sorry it wasn't me
yeah they're in the road what
how
[Music]
that's ridiculous
there's a there's a law right are we
no we're not closer hey hey i need your
car oh you [ __ ]
every [ __ ] time i press x instead of
being okay
come on where is it
come on
i'll go to the [ __ ] animals club
it's super far isn't it no it isn't
not that bad maybe we're even closer now
yeah we are look at that it was all part
of the plane
hey look
correct uh december's membership is
going to red nose day
whoa
uh they're all driving on the wrong side
[Music]
and then they get mad at me
damn
[ __ ] dope no no stop calling please
you don't know me but you will you don't
know me but here i am
deal with downtown city center
this is downtown [ __ ] yeah what about
you hot stuff
need anything you call me remember
nego knows everybody
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] other crazy
i think i'm the best driver in this game
see that perfect turn every time
over here at last excuse me
and here we are excellent
no i i went
no why didn't no one tell me
this is why you're here
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] it's fine trust me it's fine
all right out of my [ __ ] way out of
my way i ain't got time
it was not me
you won't believe this keanu reeves is
in my head i didn't do nothing
ghost rider vibes hell yeah
nicholas cage is there the only one that
could match
here on the reefs i think
since we're gonna work together
thank you
perfect oh remember
i i can't while we're at it
we need fresh wheels i do actually mine
is on fire
out of the way hombre whoa
360 met off man [ __ ]
y'all saw that [ __ ] best driver
watch it 360 again
almost [ __ ]
it wasn't me
at last animals club
all right let's kill some people
oh nice oh we can take this afterwards
oh i like it you
think you could just get in for free how
do i get in
uh out of my way out of my [ __ ] way
yo he's got ksi tattooed you think
you're some kind of hot [ __ ] you can get
in anyway
nothing to think about i know it so step
the [ __ ] aside
all right [ __ ] go it works exactly
like this in real life
that's why i knew that would work okay
then
you can go thank you
thank you i belong here hey how are you
doing
oh these guys look tough don't they hey
we're cool right
i'm just chilling bro uh oh it's a fight
club
who's next [ __ ] anyone else whoa it's
abby
got a fight lined up here
that's so don't look familiar to me you
fresh meat here
am i kidding abby is way stronger well
watch yourself then they don't like
strangers here
one wrong look and you're crawling
through the gutter on busted legs
but you defeat me i can
vouch for you to the right folks don't
want to fight here's the
with the trainer that kind of stuff uh
thanks
appreciate it i'd say you're welcome
but there's still the matter of
defeating me and full disclosure
i've never i think we're gonna get our
ass kicked she's
she's an all zebra diet you say you've
never lost
i say there's a first time for
everything ah oh jesus
sorry to say you'll be disappointed oh
[ __ ] i'm dead
i'm dead why did i do this just
i ain't going i ain't going no
[ __ ] no okay good tech under the hood
sensory can i shoot her boosted core
you're about to find out ah true
true all right there shall we
true let's get to it
good luck all right all right i got this
[ __ ] went down like a harder the harder
they
they harder they punched the bigger they
i'm dead i won i watched i was not even
i i can't find the accent
at last um
oh this changes the game no
i will never get boots but i will get
pants
they look comfy
that looks kind of snazzy doesn't it
yeah that looks cool [ __ ] yeah
all right which one this one right at
least
at least we got a bike what the [ __ ] is
this
my back's on fire abby's cheating
she's on roids it's not fair
or i can level up um [ __ ] what should i
do then
that was way too hard
damn that looks dope
oh here we go
[Music]
yes
no
what happened the game lag
oh my [ __ ] god
stream still up
ah yes just where we left off
[Music]
this is why you get the bike [ __ ] yeah
did the legs stop still lagging
careful now
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
whoa
can you talk
i guess the stream is crashed anyway
doesn't [ __ ] matter
nice nade bro
thank you that's very generous of you
stay vigilant
[Applause]
are we back is it working
youtube is uh overcooked
right they won't [ __ ] leave me alone
i missed you guys
thank you thank you
what a thrill there will be a meeting
you me and this friend of mine
you will tell him what you told me
oh my god are you serious
he's got another
[Music]
the cost of this cutting-edge therapy
treatment right so then what
you will tell him what you told me the
truth of
events i have little hope that
heart warning limp dick warning what the
[ __ ] you're saying
location
all right i did it let me shoot hey feet
about to start you uh
gotta take a piss or something uh now's
the time
thanks for your concern let's start this
rodeo
just yet not till you get in the range
go on set up chop chop
chop it choppy i speak japanese
what's up fellas this is mine
all righty how many we got just six
goddamn well no point crying about it
rules are simple right there's the
target shoot it
don't matter which one go on and shoot
your neighbors most hits wins
uh meaning hits on the target not your
neighbor
oh right uh small caliber iron only
don't go showing off with your [ __ ]
assault bangers or no rocket pukers got
me
first prize is a pistol but uh
a real nice one oh nice i'm telling you
all right real [ __ ] nice gun is
coming up
can i not shoot with this
draw name your weapon so i have to use a
three [ __ ]
two hey hey the hell is this the hell
you're doing with that double barrel
said small
caliber okay okay okay let me pick the
right one
i should put a scope on it shouldn't i
can i not
this is a small caliber
can i i swear i had a scope on one of my
guns
can i put that one on
nope [ __ ] i wasted a bunch of time for
no reason
i have two scopes
only all right i forgot my iron
must be in my other jacket
get the [ __ ] out of my sight now let's
pop some cherries
chill i'm going i'm going
pearls before swine for [ __ ] sake i
thought it was me that [ __ ] that
all right three two
one
i probably shouldn't reload
this is really weird
halfway there me going gun
thank you
am i just supposed to shoot it once
oh i see i was i didn't [ __ ] see the
side first thing stop
everyone stop we're done
first place fee second
rooney rest your bush league punks
learn to shoot out of my sight now
gun
thanks wilson oh okay
uh-huh yeah
hey everything okay
[Laughter]
ain't a damn thing that's right contest
didn't do [ __ ]
didn't sell a goddamn thing oh try not
call them potential buyers
bush league yeah maybe but
[ __ ] god's something you gotta respect
you don't know how to shoot don't do it
take care v
i'm sorry man i'm sorry
hey it's not your fault man
it's society
ooh is that is there a weapon vendor
oh it's this guy oh we're here i didn't
realize
all right then i can sell all this crap
how much i'm gonna have 12k not bad
ooh legendary katana what do i need for
it
i don't have the money how much does it
cost 32k what the [ __ ]
exactly all right we know what we're
saving for now
mr stern
how is the game on playstation and xbox
by the way
i see people meme it a lot
all right let's go to afterlife see why
do they ask me which car i want when i
only have one option
it's so stupid
what are they doing the [ __ ] are you
doing
what
what did i do
what the [ __ ] you want nothing
oh they're [ __ ] following me dude
let me in hey here you go thank you
thank you
no this trouble the net around me
you won't it you know it i lost
everything
let me be plain again solve your own
problems clean up your
[ __ ] go [ __ ] yourself ew
be careful what the [ __ ] dude
need a fixer got something that can't
wait
let him in [ __ ] yeah
hmm not here not there
who are you name's v and what is it you
want
v all these years
really come walk on the couch guiana you
know just kicking it back on a couch
yeah i'm switching to a mouse with jack
in uh 15 minutes
give her lead your services gotta track
a guy down
mm-hmm anders hellman hotshot engineer
work for arisaka
millisec anders hellman
pinpoint him for me
thanks jump in too soon first
my help's got a price second and third
dexter desean jackie welts t-buck
multiple bells ring and be left a lot of
bodies behind
death walks in your wake chalk that up
to bad luck
there's the [ __ ] i know ask her about
suck and tell
that why she's older shot me up right in
front of her
want to go through obits really fine
johnny silverhat zeroed inside our
socket tower
before your very eyes got more if you
want
or we could just talk got balls on you
boy
don't like that on everybody but they
seem to sue you
thanks anyways feelings be damned i've
always said
this is pure biz you need my help so get
those eddies ready
mm-hmm see [ __ ] you know i'm not paying
15 grand
and if i don't have the scratch it's
[ __ ] off and have a nice day
no more like come back when you do
them's the brakes
then see you soon you know where to find
me
no no
no no 50 i'm saving
[ __ ] i'm saying for a legendary sword
hey interested in some work yes i need
money please
a business opportunity cargo transport
good for me to be
quick and quiet okay yes i'm listening
it's simple you go to the kabuki
waterfront collect the package give me a
call
then i tell you how to deliver it very
straightforward
yeah everything except my pay 15 grand
don't worry there's a bonus in it for
you imported and duty-free
duty-free and detail-free yes but all
together fair
it's a simple job generously
compensating
do you accept yeah sure i mean
good i knew we'd find acceptable terms
head to the kabuki waterfront then
search for a fridge with the words
no future once you locate it collect
what you find inside
then call me for further instructions
till then i guess
big in japan
how far is it nine enemies
what is happening here welcome to night
city
is that on purpose
hello you okay bro can't you see
i'm get busy honest job
bro you're being dominated right now
cringe dude hey look what kiana
what don't pester me
easter egg a little easter egg by the
devs nice
you're my [ __ ] rhyme
what the [ __ ] this game is so broken
every god damn
second bro get off my bike
oh thanks
oh my god dude
oh don't hit the cops hey caps hey dude
[ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
can i i got i got this
there we go nice and clean baby
oh [ __ ] wrong turn
i did on purpose of course
hey i don't think i know you
since i need help okay you need a driver
for street races i'm an excellent driver
your garage where is it an arroyo from
valley
lovely
they don't let you finish anything until
these they give you another thing
there we go
got a simple clean cut gig told me
yep
oh hey there hey
okay we gotta find the fringe now if i
was a fridge where would i
be hmm
hmm yes
hey lady you seen a fridge
[Music]
hey man you got fridge
cool arcade [ __ ] are you doing
[Music]
bridge fridge
does it point to it when i'm or is it
just like this is the
okay we checked there
oh it has to be in here somewhere
maybe out here fridge
it's not a big area there we go is that
it no
is this the fridge
the [ __ ] is that
is it in one of the houses
is it
house by the water
i haven't checked here i don't trust the
guys
it's not that many places to look at
it must be in here we checked here
it must be in here
check there [ __ ]
there we go whoa it's keanu reeves
oh [ __ ] he's in rough shape
but alive let's hear what dennis has to
say
hey got a status find the package oh
yeah he's chilling
he's a little worse for wear but no
issues what's next
i prepared a car for you put the man in
the trunk and head to north side
the address is in the gps okay
one more thing watch for tigers they've
got their sights trained on your new
companion
what [ __ ] hung up
i have to carry this [ __ ] no hey
oh yeah hush little baby
don't you cry papa's gonna
poop booty bye and if that food
hey i'm holding him are you serious you
cannot be serious
i'm just carrying a man what's the issue
here
how do i put you down
bro you almost got me killed dude
stay down
sorry i got a plan b
oh [ __ ] your tumblr haircut
[ __ ] your tumblr
smart weapons require smart luck to
unlock full potential of the target to
install one
visit the trusted ripper don all right
one more dude the sword is too good
[Music]
oh
where's where is he hey where's the
where's the guy
oh he's right there hush little baby
don't you cry
you're safe here with pewdiepie
no i'm just smuggling a man
oh god check what's that jack message me
i don't have time okay yeah let me just
finish this quest one sec sorry
how can i leave this guy hanging
it's almost done i know i'm supposed to
hurry but there's
luke right here sorry oh god all right
it was a hot dog
okay hey
[ __ ] are you doing here we go
you want this
what is happening did i just breach
protocol with this guy
oh god this is becoming so much more
complicated
get out it's stuck
oh my god
what is happening it's stuck
bro it oh
i did it bro you just got
hacked and now you got hacked in real
life
[ __ ] god damn there's a lot of them
yeah take it all
i didn't expect so many
that's the shot i needed
should i just can i save here
[ __ ] all right for the batter
yes okay
among us everyone's favorite
[ __ ] gun i [ __ ] that should use my ak
[Music]
i'm jumping on disk
hello
hey hey hey what's up greenman
not much mr sweden mr sweden
yeah yeah
i failed because someone wrote me on
whatsapp
and that's the main reason
it's not because you stink no i stink
hey
you're live right yes a
shout out to the jacksepticeyes
i can't believe they donated something
because we prefer to call it be called
decepticons okay
it's the septicons what a bunch of
generous people legit that's amazing
congrats i know it's unreal yeah
i i know one more generous person who
did a really nice thing
santa claus yes
sinter class hey um
how was your day pretty good yeah
got led lights installed in my closet
[ __ ] yeah look at you mr handyman hell
yeah
oh bro somebody in my chat is just
immediately like roast felix
uh he's had a hard day guys no no i had
a good day i can take it
you can take it and green man
all right [ __ ] you how dare you roast me
on my top
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
you know how it is yeah
i i still don't know how to live stream
on youtube properly
i don't either i went live today and all
my settings that work on twitch suddenly
youtube was like
we're gonna lag every 10 seconds it's
been laggy for me too yeah
i don't know how to premiere it or
whatever still
oh like schedule it yeah i just i hit
live like
and it just goes immediately yeah it's
confusing when i did it before it
started two different live streams
the schedule one was still there and
then i was live on a different stream
but we're here and we're doing good
things [ __ ] yeah
i mean [ __ ] yeah i mean [ __ ] yeah
you can swear freak
i can't do it on command i guess he
guess he can't
[ __ ] [ __ ]
i don't have an among us thumbnails no
one dog yeah
the vine video hey can you say something
wait what is that i thought that was my
thing god damn it
no that's a vine dude ah
you're late to the game ah [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
[Laughter]
missed opportunity hello boys hello what
up is that content creator of the year
valtteri
congratulations whoa content creator of
the year valkyrie
all right goodbye i love content creator
of your valkyrie
is that what it was called content
creator i
somehow i i won it this year i don't
know why
somehow it's not because you've been
killing somehow i
i anyways congrats jack on uh
one million that's everybody yeah it's
not my million it's our million
congrats to one male and congrats to me
for installing led lights
oh yeah oh [ __ ] yeah congrats thank you
all by myself
oh that's right we don't need bubbles
we're doing proximity chat
we are yeah our favorite time when
cycuno gets
absolutely unleashed yeah wait jack what
do you mean
he's a different man when he plays
proximity chat i love it
well i i s as we have fun right yeah
what happened you guys killed me
crazy oh god not you too
jack oh jesus you guys killed me
is that it yeah you got to put your hand
up to your mouth when you say it
last night we killed him after he said
it was him and he said
you guys killed me wait this soda just
like him it's really good
chad is so good i've been workshopping
it for a while
charlie are you there hello friend
everybody
hey charlie hey grace been a while
felix how are things going good good i
installed led lights today
very good you're very proud sean
congratulations you're [ __ ]
crushing it today thank you i don't
think i can take full credit for that
no that's all you entirely sean i said
i'll dye my hair green and everyone else
was like oh i bet
yeah now you know the price of that
or the green hair i know that's
jack you [ __ ] freak you know what you
did yeah
jack what i'm a nasty freak corpse you
know me
you're a dirty boy you're a real dirty
boy today sean
i'm on the naughty list this year i was
watching you dye your hair i wanted to
puke that was yucky
it was it felt yucky it still looks
yucky i don't know if it turned out
green
but i'm happy with it one more time it'd
definitely be green like no regrets
it's a little less caramel green than
i'm used to but it looks good
yeah you're just like that radioactive
waste kind of green right now
that's the cyberpunk theme
can you guys still be friends with me
uh no one said that hey how's the levels
by the way guys
so good are they loud am i loud
i just don't think anyone wanted to be
your friend to be honest that would just
if it's over charlie stop i put the code
in general
okay yeah
everyone have that installed i thought i
still charlie have you done procs
never i haven't touched it don't know
how it works
[Music]
it's pretty simple download something
called crew link
so it's a third third-party software is
it like a malware or something you give
me a trojan
yeah it definitely is great but um we
haven't been hacked yet
yeah i think charlie's the first one to
ever also be concerned about that
yeah it's kind of true that's true
usually everyone gives into the hype and
just instantly downloads it
[ __ ] that's what i did you'll have to
leave me too jack
independent okay encoder exe that we're
all blindly executing
um i'm just gonna
i'm hungry man i'm hungry all the time
all the time
all day every day i'm just gonna
probably
that's such a big man
i got these shitty ass protein bars
i bought them bulk online now i regret
it
this is nothing nothing
oh
oh wow oh you do that
it tastes amazing though i'll give them
that
tips on not how not to procrastinate
how random but i have the perfect
solution make a list
[ __ ] make a list of all the [ __ ] you
got to do
and then just pick them up
that's the secret of getting [ __ ] done
anyway back to the people that's
it wait did the code get leaked who are
these people i might have leaked it
a couple times a couple i still need the
uh
proximity thing so uh it doesn't work
for me maybe i have an old version
error um yeah i need to get it again
what version do you guys have mom is
1.1.9
yeah i'm on point two as well no
function but we can't find
the link to it easily i have the page
open but i forget what to
link to oh this is one of those
confusing websites
yeah it's github yeah i never understand
what to click on
you just click the accruing setup.exe
does ryan reynolds stop by today sean uh
ryan reynolds
jk stopped by so i put him on the board
as the real one
okay that's good that was probably the
real one yeah
absolutely he's a jokester you know him
he's just playing around he's deadpool
bro [ __ ] around all the time
uh felix is he can you hear me okay
felix thank you for your donation by the
way did you come through
yeah amazing nice we all freaked out
about it and you were different so you
couldn't oh nice
excellent now we said oh jesus a lot
he reacts the way that i do when i
accidentally spend ten dollars on
something on amazon oh
okay
see i in my head when i do that it
sounds so good but then i heard hear
myself doing i'm like [ __ ] this
[ __ ] this i'm not doing that impression
same
people are like you're so good at voices
dude and then i hear it back and like
was i
yeah and then i'm like oh it's so good
in my head all the time
everyone are liars
you guys need help yeah i i'm stuck help
okay click the link that rage you're
saying oh nice
click the one that corp said go straight
to them oh that's better
that's way better and then just click
the one that has the exe on it yeah yeah
right
what's up toast toast you made it
he's on his way he's in a meeting
he's easy he's a businessman on business
so yeah that donation is thanks to you
guys
i really appreciate it i'm really proud
that we can support charity every
month
oh yeah good job shake hand
yeah i don't normally do handshakes but
grab a few people jackie procrastinated
here
uh wait wait jackie how many dying my
hair how many he made a lobby of seven
people and decided
says seven people um
that's okay you got a million i'm sure
we could find it to be fair
i messaged toast and toast is like yeah
i can get people together and i was like
cool because i'm
all over the place and oh
oh you guys are playing wow yeah
dungeons are great mm-hmm
um i i might have one i'll message ethan
and see if he wants to join
yes that'd be great let me know if you
need help finding people
i'm struggling with this version too
please use another voice server
oh i just got the same issue this is all
fixable
yeah link them link them the thing that
we're currently using
oh the thing what it's the
god more malware failed status code
522 you just you just copy that link
into the
voice server ray can help you probably
yeah i'm pasting it into general
um so copy that url and then go to the
way ahead of you
already got it got it yeah oh you did
that already and then okay now close the
whole thing out
i'm not as smart as felix okay so i got
cop
you don't have to say that to the url
and paste it in the voice server
box and then once that's in there you
close the whole thing
and make sure among us is closed as well
and then re-open
the app first and then open the game
with that oh boy oh
boy i feel like i'm back in school again
with these uh these instructions here
i'm a little lost here
i'm luster so i open internet explorer
so do i need to change my password or
something so i've got cogwheel open
okay and then did you copy the link the
url link that i just posted
yeah where does that go okay that goes
in the voice server box just scroll down
settings cog wheel and scroll down okay
okay i didn't see there was a scroll
option
okay if you're streaming turn off show
lobby code
but and then close the whole thing out
after that's pasted
and then make sure among us is closed as
well that's the setting now
you can turn that out yeah
i accidentally showed the lobby code
with it the last time
yeah yeah um ethan's playing
phasmaphobia right now so he said
if we need one in for a while then we
can
thanks ethan can we start inviting
people
yeah toast i think he thought you were
going to invite the rest of the people
sorry how do i turn off the show there's
always people around it's mongoose
do i turn up to show the code okay go to
settings and then it's right below
the server voice server box this is show
lobby code just check that off
oh it's in that thing okay cool yeah
i thought it was a game and charlie i
think it i haven't gotten an error yet
so i think it's working okay
okay okay so we will um i'll make a new
lobby and you could test it out in there
and you'll have to define and discord
because it might mess with the settings
a little bit oh mine still shows wait
who the [ __ ] are these guys
you guys aren't juanito and dora right
no
no that's me that's me wait wait is this
you guys
oh she said when she said it would hide
the lobby code she met like within the
program not within the actual
game itself why would i share the
program
hey some people oh double that who's
talking
oh can you hear me can you hear me yeah
but are you talking to the right people
yeah can you hear me
felix felix uh i guess no it should work
i see my thing work
you see it i don't see it i see it go up
and down can you hear me hello
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah blah
it's you not me oh it's working now yeah
am i working you're working don't you
appear
what
yeah you're right okay is it better now
okay i can't hear felix though why can
no one hear me
control r to reset the app while you're
in game
okay i hear you guys perfect perfect
control r good good good good but it's
working
hello it's me you joined the
cooling thing already excellent
okay perfect charlie
tina hi tina do you need help hi
uh can you just hear me in game yeah
yeah it works well
you're in you're in my right ear it
feels very cozy
keep saying stuff thank you for being
here today very quiet can you say
that's what i'm talking about yeah it's
kind of
so the the proximity chat you can't
adjust the volume
individually all right
so uh if i stand if i stand on top of
you guys does it get louder
like we all stand up here and then we
run down or something like that
um oh no it's been leaked who's the
leader come
on i i [ __ ] up oh that's it's okay if
it's jack
yeah you raised a million dollars
here we'll make a new one no not
all right i got one more coming as well
i i was up until 6am playing waterford
that's the old good old days isn't it
i'm trying to pick which
nice nice
do i dare to click on chat hey
what's up guys
[ __ ] among us dude
you cannot see it in the mirror
all right if you see in the mirror
what's the code then
if they can see the code in your mirror
i will
go to their house and kiss them oh you
hear that guys
to talk so that way i can like say
thanks yeah there is control
mutes the crew link oh okay
no no you can't you can talk to chad
it's fine no
i don't want to be intrusive especially
not on it sean's thank miss
you have a you have a red ring we're all
here together charlie
we've already hit our goal many times
can you hear me right now
oh no yes okay so control plus
r didn't
i like how i asked you jackie yesterday
you were like i don't know is it too
high are we gonna hit the goal
check your stream like 30 minutes in
yeah you were dying your hair like when
i woke up this morning
for like an hour oh we
we're lost then whatever i don't like
him anyway
i feel like i'm a professional at this
now
both earbuds
oh that's probably gonna make a big
difference actually so control r
didn't work so how could i mute the crew
link
oh you should probably leave the lobby
if you hit push to talk
charlie you can pick what button you
wanted
oh was there a push to talk in crew link
i didn't see that when i was setting it
up i'll just do that yeah it's in the
settings and then you can pick which
button you want
maybe that'll be better wait don't open
the game yet
oh okay are we are we missing people
okay try putting in the voice server
and click the cogwheel and then put it
on in that this link
is that a yes or no
cool what felix i don't know uh are we
missing people
we have people missing in the lobby but
i think we're full now oh
yeah yeah they're almost here they're
close they're close i think
we could use one more person all right
preferably someone that has this all
installed already
no you're totally fine okay okay um
after you paste the server link in the
thing then close the whole thing out
and then reopen the app first and then
it'll open the game
then you should be good that's so weird
talking now everyone hears me
um okay so i'm just over here
last christmas no copyright now
oh [ __ ] you're right what are you doing
you should know this on twitch now oh
wait you're not on twitch
you hate me i love that
that's dmca free right right corpse
right corpse
i ain't got no label i ain't got no
i do what i want i'm a free bird
i run with the wolves whoa like you hate
me
but you love me loki
[Music]
can you hear me right now yeah yeah we
can hear you yeah yeah yeah so if i do
give a remake right because i'm sorry i
definitely mean
that better guys i'm sorry oh my [ __ ]
god
corp sounds good even unprocessed audio
what the [ __ ]
someone what's that
look in the mirror all you want [ __ ]
yo
yo this is so cool i've never played
proximity
gonna be our bag one second
am i still here
nice
control so next to your arrow keys it
defines all of crew link but you have to
be clicked into
among us to do it
i'm holding it right i just hit it it
still didn't work right
weird usually like a icon shows up on
your thing in crewlink saying that
you're deafened
how are the levels now does push to talk
not work is it good
i'm sure it does it just makes you
really quiet i i don't know that i'm
super alive for me
oh wait now you're good
okay [ __ ] jesus okay oh jesus
weird
[Music]
ew
all right some say plain some say plan
but really the english language is a
living thing that
is always changing so that's true it
could be planned it could be played
[Music]
just like jeans can be jeans because it
sounds nicer it rolls up the tongue
let's speak in swedish since they don't
know swedish and i know swedish and they
don't
do you know swedish groups
everyone just adds a bunch of syllables
so many languages yeah i speak eight
languages with like three sentences
sakuna you look different i'm sick oh i
have a present yeah
um well besides i know a little bit do
you want to know what's in the box i i
do want to know what's in there here let
me show you
thanks miss jack what's in my box i feel
like
swedish and confused
in your box
she threw it away oh no that's the
it's inside the box yeah you put on is
what's inside
my heart was in that box hot boot
[Applause]
and you threw it away oh your your heart
looks like an egg to me
does anybody know how to stop does
anybody else have the problem where
tina you're working yesterday everyone's
working she died
i live it's fine everyone ready it's
beautiful
thank you let's go everyone though we
can't find one person
oh yeah sorry what i'm sure what what
rules
are we doing someone will see our exams
surely that's just normal except you
could talk to anyone
yeah we can do a warm-up so you're
allowed to speak during gameplay
yeah yeah you have this big thing
gameplay that's the only way to
know that's a lot of pressure i don't
know if i can
oh yeah again
i do have to tell you guys something
though when i play voice chat i usually
like don't do my tasks i just hang out
with people you know
[Music]
let's go do a task together okay you
won't kill me right
no would you kill me
[Music]
i wouldn't kill you in cafeteria
i'm downloading 14 28.
85 96 100.
uh yours was off your sword oh i mean
i wasn't downloading i was i was
counting you oh i see
right here we gotta go over here happy
merry oh okay
see everyone can hear you if uh oh wait
i wanna see
oh wait light our lights on
why yeah yeah yeah look i got it i gotta
tell you a secret
i'm not listening um i'm listening oh
wait you're both listening no this is
awkward
[Laughter]
uh no but but if i was i would i would
tell you
okay i trust you oh hey pewds what's up
any killing going on uh no no no not
that i've seen so far but but i'll let
you know if i kill anybody
what what did you think
one inelectrical hmm
i'm gonna get you wait what kill me on
cam
i'm gonna i'm gonna kill him good i
really like that okay and then i'm gonna
go leave electrical in the corner
this is where i died why did i i just
came right
no no no you do not i'm not
no shame on you shame on you for shame
on you
for even thinking about it this is a
task right here oh
is anyone in here oh yeah you're right i
told you i'm safe all right yeah you're
looking you're looking for someone
uh get out post get out she might be
calling your partner
i just saved your life my hero thank you
felix
you're welcome there we can just bully
everyone
get out [ __ ] out get out get out get the
[ __ ] out
shoosh shame shame shame
yes oh that is kind of sus
oh no oh if you want to live don't worry
i'll vent
out i'll vent out
please close your eyes it doesn't work
because it says thank you oh
oh jesus oh
what happened didn't i leave grease ball
with mr pewds
in electrical they told me to get out
they told me to get out so i left
yeah and now he's saying all right can i
can i explain
what happened yeah yeah i could explain
okay
me and [ __ ] were bullying people
and then
yeah i was getting bullied so
it adds up so far yes yeah that sounds
pretty good yeah and then one other
person came
in and bullied us who was it valkyrie
get her out how did she bully why didn't
you report well why wouldn't you
they yelled at me you guys they yelled
at me they said get out of here
wait wait they said that to me too
yelled at ray yeah
they said get out get out the treatment
the same treatment
i trust tafu and rey hmm
we were all in advent i said hey look
there's someone in o2 and well i ran
into
jack i was protected okay wow thank miss
special i'm
she's been very good don't make a
mistake here i'm clean it's about great
she did it right in front of me
and she even did that ah thing yeah
okay i think that speaks here
do we skip on seven i'm willing to skip
oh that's true it probably was both
imposters going no i voted for her and
i'm not oh
oh oh toast stay the [ __ ] away from me
about it
no no no oh gosh you can hear me
pretty good and not for a night you know
[ __ ] dumbass
yeah all right
can't believe she did grease ball like
that disgusting
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
what do we do all we have to do is
double crochet
my god oh my god oh my god
he's there oh you get in there
so i i heard two people
saying something about a double kill
still look like we me and we and ray we
just walked up on the
on the body and we were freaking out we
were freaking out and then
yeah and he kept saying double kill we
need a double kill
wait wait wait when did i say that also
we don't need a double kill we only need
one more kill
okay all right listen valkyrie first
i don't know then psychonauts back
what are your thoughts yeah what are
your thoughts
yeah jack and ha told us i'm clicking
true
wait have we voted anyone off yet no we
haven't no there's two killers for sure
oh my god
next time lock the door okay
you guys are pinning both on
i mean sounded like he was in the last
round too
but i will say me and where he walked up
on these bodies we freaked out
we wouldn't have stayed on the body if
we were imposters
yeah you're right that makes sense
actually you know what maybe it isn't
them after all yeah
wait guys follow your instinct
i'm trusting wait no no this is
something i'm wrong
that was so wrong it's all true we were
freaking out because i accidentally
killed
jack
okay i didn't even know that was
possible
what what does this happen
are you no no no i i made her do it i
made her do it
uh okay
is no one speaking or is it quiet
wait i can't hear you guys now
got to restart it and now it's all just
like that is special right
thank you yeah for anyone who if breaks
for you you have to click on the app and
press control r and then it
resets everything yeah that worked um i
also i
i hesitated i i was once i would do it
but i didn't
i wait do we not have attention
how do we not have a tenth person in the
whole world can
uh
well well well hello you want to join
candidates oh you're including my
childhood it'll be fun just downloading
dancing
i'll send you a link on what side if you
want to join
with me real quick ray likely story
over here oh i can't hear cycling
is pewdiepie not here you can't hear
saikuno
were you apologizing for killing me oh
yes i was it was an
accident and um i can't believe it
hey what's good what are you doing
uh i'm
what's going on i don't i don't know
you don't know no why you whispering
because you whisper and then i just
whisper back
hello oh yeah
can you smell my breath ah
all right what'd you see wait tina are
you actually
oh oh this is real this is interesting i
was running to hoffa saying i'm going to
kill you
i'm going to kill you i heard that
remember
i heard that you heard that yeah i
remember tina hunting her down like a
maniac yeah that's crazy
saikuno told me to go kill her and so i
went to go kill her
yeah and then you killed her just dead
somewhere but i
didn't kill her
jack what do you think is it tina this
is a sick time am i just getting special
treatment because
it's thankfus no happy thing what do you
want i mean
i did kind of say tina go kill hafu and
then hafu died so i kind of wanted
to do it
i'll
no tina i appreciate it i didn't think
you'd actually do it just because i
terror you know i was trying to cause a
problem you did you killed somebody you
did you killed her caused a lot of chaos
i believed in you uh it's 100
you know i think it's psycho
wait you think it's me yeah it could be
me
oh my god we killed her you guys we
killed her i can't believe it okay i
actually voted
wait for her but i was waiting tina
who'd you vote for
i voted to skip no one i forgot to tina
who's you walking what
you guys are crazy corpse corpse we
gotta go have a disney hey
i just have a resting [ __ ] face that's
why
are you hiding the corner uh
he's safe sean i can tell
they'll never find me here oh oh hi
hey hey hey you might have to check your
audio in windows as well
for some reason it shoves mine down to
like 50 for some reason
uh doing some tasks hey uh
we're just troubleshooting yeah yeah
yeah
yeah wait because if your voice is quiet
then no one's gonna be able to hear you
and then you get talked over and then
it's annoying oh my like my mic
the default one yeah oh i gotcha yeah
because it's it's quiet now
thanks bro
[ __ ] balcony
no you're not i i'm not you're right
charlie don't give away our strats
[Music]
nobody else does their tests by the way
charlie just meeting you
all right we're all dead over here this
is the dead cool
tina it actually wasn't here apologize
for voting me out and the other one
you know you guys were walking together
i was like two people wouldn't do that
we totally did i killed you right in
front of the floor
and to be fair i did tell you to hunt
her down and kill her when she was dead
huh i think jack has this can you guys
hear a corpse oh my god that's live
yes yeah oh i can't hear him you could
try
again yeah and then if it doesn't work
then then he has to
boost your lash cup so glitchy
okay go ahead i was i was with valkyrie
but i do like that
and she's mad at him i don't say the
code word she kills him and i'm like all
right
you know what that's [ __ ] up i'm gonna
make you killing a crowd now
so i walked up to the nearest crowd and
said babushka so she'd have to do it and
so we'd vote her out
so it's like a winter soldier thing okay
but the fact that charlie jumped so
quick on me being the second one makes
me think that this is him
sean can vouch for me i was near him and
felix that whole round
oh you can hear me oh yeah
what the [ __ ] you know gets murdered in
front i got ludwig to come yeah
we have a tent and you don't report to
bob nice okay it's toast
never mind i change my mind it has to be
toasted everybody has said each other's
names i'm so confused
let us all hit the skip button while
jack does his task
oh i've already voted for corpse just a
heads up oh
that would have been helpful i mean i
think it's pretty clear but i'm all
on board for this strat too who is the
other one
it's jack oh
i actually don't know who is go ahead
jack
ah space
the final frontier the vastness of the
universe
cannot be comprehend by the simple mind
so beautiful yet so peaceful
whoa oh that freaked me out
yeah yeah yeah
yeah i can yeah please get in here
i don't know how long i'll play though
but yeah
i sent him the link for the download
so you download the thing you open the
thing you go into settings
you add you copy and you paste that
server i sent you
okay
now you have to believe me what happened
it was dark it was dark i know i was on
my way
to fix it because you guys wanted 50 50
me
why didn't you stay who makes the better
argument go
i didn't see you run towards lights oh
my god i saw you right now
me he saw him briefly oh my god i saw
his
his legs in the dark for a second i
don't know
where i have a tenth guy by the way if
you guys i don't know i'm not even there
back down right after
i think ray said ludwig already right
i'm in storage
i did yeah i did get attention uh okay
oh wait didn't posters say he got a
tenth
oh god oh sorry ken oh
it's the same corpse killed charlie i'm
sorry my man now he's blaming me
ludwig's already in the discord
oh it's probably the same tenth
i thought this was just of course
wait huh shouldn't you be blaming me
this is this could be aren't you guys
all together corpse this could be a big
brain play by coin no
i already voted say that before you know
i i this could be a play by toast but i
think it's true then do the safe thing
and skip
oh wait wait how is that the safe those
wild games really made you oh the lights
are off
all right you should have got your z's
bro
and then if corpse hits the button he's
probably
all right he didn't kill me
though i don't know if his cooldown is
up all right he just said
well what was that what was that last
thing you said before that
that round handed jack yeah jack
you said something at the end uh
babushka
no you said uh fingers you should have
got more sleep toast or something like
that
yeah that was kind of what you mean by
that jack yeah
because i'm worried about your health
like not getting your sleep is bad for
you and then like waking up going to bed
at 6am like your internal clock's just
going to be all off
i see that it was looking out factual
also jack i also saw you up there too
[Music]
oh no jack oh my god i was like
oh jack
[Laughter]
sorry everybody that you had to witness
that
i had no idea hey we won
guys yeah we were talking they thought
it was everyone else but you
really yeah yeah i thought it was so
obviously me
that's what everyone thinks in the dark
oh um um so i got
ludwig in the call already but toast did
you already have a tenth and then
also said he had a tenth i guess i have
a backup number three
okay i can laugh hello
i had no but i can oh okay okay do you
have to control r after every game
no sometimes it glitches yeah
like give it some time all right
[Music]
ready lead
okay potty break two minutes
right so should i turn them up or me
down wait corpse you knew it was me
right the whole time
what what toast you knew it was me the
whole time right no that was charlie
the [ __ ] i would have played so much
harder
boys what's up
boys just hanging with the bulls
them up really they're so loud for me
the boys
dude my in my group they won't shut the
[ __ ] up about the boys right tina what's
up ludwig welcome back to among
us hello lovely to be here with all the
boys
oh my freaking god the girl that uh
content creator of the year valkyrie is
in the server
you announced this wow hey ray i did i
was very happy that i got to announce it
i'm so glad you announced it jack that
was so cool yeah you did really good it
was so much worse
i would not have been able to read
[ __ ] cringe anyone else announcing
the stream jack no but seriously
congrats i'm very happy for you oh
how do i do this jack i'm happy for you
too you know you're doing you know
you're doing
things and stuff and uh i dye my hair
it's pretty big
sing your christmas songs i was
listening to it on my stream it's fire
got it
it's cold outside
[Laughter]
i would love to hear that do it the
entire way around the mountain m-w-e-r-c
ray wait can i talk to you okay oh wait
i'm gonna push the talk okay there we go
we can truce because i'm not imposter
you're not but i just i don't want to
die again
i'll protect you my queen i feel like
someone's gonna kill me
no no no no no no no no i'm innocent you
have to go
through me listen sorry for killing you
it's okay he said the code word
wait who said the code you actually hit
us at this time
conveniently every time we're about to
play ludwig it's not like a convenience
thing i i had
my power went out my internet was a
little shoddy i love playing because i
like playing with you
oh ray i don't like playing with it
so i'm just glad that what i don't know
last round you were chasing uh
guys guys guys important information uh
they're [ __ ] talking at us over there
who knocked it right let's get him look
at him
i didn't say anything i you were you
spreading did you say it was me
uh can't believe it
oh welcome back charlie all right okay
do you want a free kick
don't huddle together everyone we don't
want to die in the dark
yeah yeah yeah yes i think i think it's
my turn to die
let's all stand on top of each other and
see what happens that sounds good that
sounds good
oh but if someone killed on the stack
right now
none of us would be able to stop them
this is a good stack
yeah this would be a clean stack kill my
child is looking
very thick right now wait guys i have a
theory nobody's
oh my gosh
we'll never know this theory i just have
so much cortisol
in me right now oh why is psychonaut
dead and why is there three of you on
this body it just happened toast it
happened in front of us
right now i told you someone was dead
you were right jack
all i know is cycuno's dead and rey was
within the
area code so yeah and me too and um
toast toast wait a minute i am
protecting hafu
okay i'm protecting her i'm innocent
who's on the other side of the map wait
huffle you're not on the stack
no i'm in electric okay i forgot to
protect it
but i'm alive
guys we were on a stack no no no no no
you didn't see everyone that was on the
stack in this like felix you were
yelling at the end what happened
yeah what'd you see did anyone see who
killed uh i saw blood and that's it
okay it was in your eyes it's it's hard
it burns it's like the best stat kill
i've ever seen because i didn't even see
anyone move
no yeah same um both of us are stacking
one player in this game i'll go back to
my duties protecting hafu
is that your way of like hyping yourself
upload
like i'm amazing at stack kills let's
see if they fall better
don't let it get it don't let him do it
don't let him get over here it's her
birthday ken happy birthday nobody loves
a beta compliment more than ludwig
he's just
[Music]
on the fritz he thinks it was me that
did it
because it was you can you hear us yeah
yeah i can't hear you
i don't kill saikudo first anymore i'm
gonna hear you yeah you killed me first
no okay that was just you know orangey
rng
you know
i i can't i don't have the knife hey you
did are you sure
i don't have a knife do you have a knife
corpse i don't have it
i can't hear your grease ball by the way
you might have to reset your um
press ctrl r for you guys like someone
press ctrl r i can hear
everyone here i can't i can you wait can
you hear greece paul oh not here yeah to
go
okay oh now i hear you oh here we go
okay
cool that's all working okay excellent
like a little school girls
[Laughter]
oh man something crazy happening
i'm
[Laughter]
wow holy [ __ ]
well it's not it's not jack it's
not jack i was trolling but i said i'm
gonna kill you
oh no i know we weren't here okay and
cooldowns are all over the place
what's your theory okay well often times
in life
crime begets crime do we understand this
beget
oh here we go i'm lost already sorry
no well let's just chill for a moment so
anyway
if someone in your life were to be
someone who like lies or
or maybe narc trust them right that
wasn't good enough for ray you're gonna
have to write
i'm hovering over them right now to the
rest of you what i'm trying to say is i
told seikuno in private that i didn't
like playing among us with valkyrie and
then a few months later
what did you say
wait wait wait wait wait i came up uh
pewdiepie left he was in the circle and
then valkyrie came up i think pewdiepie
knocked on me i think pewdiepie is the
imposter because he's a narc no no no
no i did not not
he's blowfiating first of all
you must die first let's go for lunch no
wait hold up we gotta tie the boat here
because
there's six uh everybody looks like the
larker get locked
what is it yeah
lark valkyrie more like larker
that's what it means yeah i skipped
letter you said you told us to vote skip
on six ludwig
don't skip on six not such a smarty
brain after all
you guys i'm glad he's dead guys we
gotta do our task
oh are you oh god it's dudes isn't it
yeah oh yeah i hope i live longer
guys hurry up oh i have a good outfit
too
wait okay should i push the button or
something an awful lot of people here
are we about to get all killed
[Laughter]
i knew felix was one but i thought ray
was the other one
what gave what could possibly have given
it away that's ridiculous
cleveland i'll remember that oh i
remember that
i was right wasn't it
you referenced another game it made no
sense
again also i'm down for polis whenever
because i love that map yeah i would
also like to play police
[Music]
all right phil i'll do a better job can
you just speak to me forever
no i don't have any tasks because i'm
imposter
wait talk about last round toast gonna
vote you out bro
i don't really i don't know what's with
me what do you gonna do huh you gonna
kill me what are you gonna do about it
yes i wish i could i wish i could stab
you right now in the neck i wish i could
do that but i can't do it
what you were gonna you're gonna stab
him in the neck she said she
wishes she could no i
all right this is my spot
what was there hello
what the [ __ ] was that
i saw it oh my god oh my god oh my god i
haven't okay
the timing of
and charlie because they were saying
they were going to kill me
charlie has an excellent vision he has
excellent vision i trust trump
works out really bad jack were you
perhaps talking about
old russian women for no reason no no no
it was a joke it was a joke yeah
wait look charlie how are you doing
something weird stop judging me
well when i make an accusation it's a
hundred percent sure
no it can't be i ran away i ran away
from ludwig
and charlie because ludwig was like i
wouldn't kill you first i would kill i
would call half at first then run away
that did happen but it was like it was
conditional it was a condition
i ran away and then same with other
everyone's saying that they were going
to kill me so i was running away the
whole time
and you felt pressured and you snapped
toast right in front of me saikuna was
behind this story
he knows that i was there yeah yeah
no yeah where's the body it's right uh
at the bottom of storage right right
before electrical
so see tina couldn't be mirror load yeah
that's you know [ __ ]
you guys are gonna skip right you guys
are gonna skip right it's really it's
really not me
i might um as far as i understand if
you're 100
sure that means you're right oh my gosh
[Music]
three people jesus charlie you're next
he's gonna get you next time
uh no okay i'm gonna fix lights for us
oh jesus charlie charlie watch out she's
gonna get
no one will find me here
no one is everyone grouping
felix hey my man
the boys are back yeah let's bully some
people
are you gonna kill me no okay cool
anybody in election hey get out
this okay okay
do it yeah yeah do it do it
do it click the button
click the button yeah we're okay elaine
oh
[Music]
little q for fun look cute here's the
cue ready
three two one
grease ball how could you do that one
as long as she leaves this is fine yeah
nothing to see here nothing get out
this is our turf you can't come what do
you mean there's no killers here
it's just charlie and felix thank you
hold on hold up i got this what is the
charity for
oh red nose day to help out food
shortages during
covet 19's pandemic thank you
because there are 265 million people in
the world that can go without food this
year
that's great god damn hey guys
is there um i feel like ludwig's
probably
um has anyone seen ludwig no oh my god
no i haven't wig he's gone
oh well oh is that you corpse oh no
that's just a regular hey get out
do that can i do my task in here no no
you gotta pay the tax
i actually don't see the body at all
okay
can the imposters close this door please
please yes okay okay here you go close
the door
three two two close this door please
okay i'm closing it up right now here
kill me next to ludwig i feel bad you
know
i don't want to wait i'm clicking the
door right now
closely if you push that goddamn door
close the goddamn door
i'm gonna close the door right now she's
gonna try and kill someone
oh she did it oh nice there we go
awesome thank you thank you
you're you're really good at that thank
you thank you
it's steve i'm gonna i'm gonna quickly
oh
our crime scene now get out of here
kill me kill two green bodies right here
just go and finish me off
tycoon can stay tina leave
all right all right i'll check the ride
do it charlie do it
well it's not a cycuno just do it just
it's fine i
i just wanted i just don't want ludwig
to be toasting alone you know
[ __ ] sake all right two green bodies
right here
what are you guys waiting for oh oh
[Laughter]
a real scooby-doo conundrum wait
felix
the gloves are coming off okay pewdiepie
and i we were walking down electric wets
are stomping around making sure
no milk drinking nerds are coming over
in our characters yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah
[ __ ] yes say it okay she blasts blood
who was there helping us
we didn't report it because it's like
you know that was brave and we can
respect that
splatoon and then saikuno comes in
lights go off felix goes oh he thinks
he's iconic it wasn't saikuna
again who vented and blasted it
i think it's charlie wait charlie how
sure are you that it's hot
i mean considering no no no no no no no
no it is
it is grease ball trolling aside it's
actually grease wait wait are you i saw
him
sure again i'm 100 sure it's baseball
you get 400. no grace
no what the [ __ ] 700
but you got it right so almost
raven kind of deserved what do you mean
i just stood over my body
like like a dance floor oh wait you're
dead oh [ __ ]
yeah i'm talking to you
does that mean i'm dead
nah
wait if you guys are dead
does that mean i'm dead
help
hey oh wow wow i can't believe it that
was very quick after you killed me jesus
all right guys i gotta call it a night i
can't believe you guys didn't kill
hoffman
bye felix have a good one bye thanks for
playing thank you
thanks so much for the donation as well
all the best
[Music]
it's not oh i'm sorry i snotted that's
disgusting
uh thanks for supporting um
with all the members and all the
donation it all goes to charity and i'm
so happy we got to donate
145 000 to thanks miss
red nose saying amazing it's a great
cause great charity keeps reporting
jack is still streaming a bunch of other
people i think jayden's doing a live
stream as well check them out
um but yeah amazing thanks for joining
us
it's a big fat brofist y'all did this i
appreciate you
handshake there you go
nice okay
you